hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play when life
no longer exists okay we put the thingy
in the thingy and hopefully the thing is
starting to work now I have no idea if
it will but I'm going to assume that it
will we are now have an empty bucket can
I refill it with water and also why was
the song only had water in it
can't you get water from a river but I
don't know okay so I'm gonna assume that
that's all taken care of and I can go on
the other rooms now I think I don't know
but then again I don't know much I'm
dumb also my voice is still kind of
hoarse so sorry if I can't if I if I'm
not as clear as I usually am because I
was yelling a lot yesterday and mmm okay
alright what do we have down here
another monster ha ha
somebody here hmm this looks suspicious
but then again everything does
especially strange boxes the Placer
Simpson Simpson is very unstable and may
explode if you're not very careful the
piston is quite rusty even though I've
been lubricating it often I keep almost
all my layouts of the machines in the
library it's quite good advices to
increase the power of the pressure
system in the library well that doesn't
help me here why didn't you just leave
it with that know where the pressure
system is so if I just yank on that knob
it's gonna blow up that what you're
trying to say why is that locked put it
back on put it back in it's obviously
holding something in there something not
good or its hopeful or it's a birthday
surprise it could be okay so if I just
yank this down it's gonna kill me right
what the hell
Wow why do I go this way oh my candle
dis man why'd you blow da man oh oh oh I
thought into something else
now did yank on the handle I thought it
was all gonna blow up hello you can't
carry too much de bris hello can you get
all through that all bad drew brees come
on come on what you got it's Kaiba we
got what oh nothing
that's right you stuck you dumb
are you dumb okay dumb he's so dumb I
bet throw something in that room that
might have been a goodie I might go back
for it later later on so what was the
point of that note saying that I needed
to go to the library and get some
special advice whatever oh this looks
like it's blocking up something
something dastardly and evil
maybe hi
what am I looking at oh you want me to
start a fire well alright then
if you really want one wait how do i how
do I wait I'll put it in there well you
don't want me to cook the wood do you
alright alright alright I'll just hang
on I'll do what you say and if it don't
work well then you're dumb okay I guess
you're dumb then her chunk start now yes
why it go dark why that happened that
shouldn't happen huh the door won't open
I bet it'll open for a monster I know
was that really hit it really oh okay I
guess that's it now and I can leave okay
all right
I won't ask questions let's just do it
and I think I can open it now okay hang
on I want to see something first I bet
there's nothing I bet there's nothing I
just want to go and see if there was
something in that room that I Oh
okay if it just fell again okay all
right it's okay it's all good it's all
good
I just want to see I just want to see ah
come on man
ah Nutter butters guess that's it damn
it I thought that was gonna be something
oh well sorry everybody
I don't even know where that stuff fell
from okay let's go through the door and
then we can turn off the giant machine
into the infernal chamber my favorite
place oh boy I love the fog okay so we
just got to get to the infernal machine
and then go down this foggy hallway John
scares whatsapp boxes who's behind me
who has the black color right someone in
front of me okay so far so nothing what
was that what what is that is that a
machine that's that's not I'm not a
monster they came to get me I hid myself
they found me there's one of my Black
Keys memories why Valkyries won't let me
be free I built her a new machine to
keep them away from me I've worked but
the machine isn't home only a machine
anymore I left one barrel full of
gunpowder Nixon machine so that I can
stop it someday the key to that room is
hidden under the middle brick next to
this table Oh
key dokey well that's handy I guess
that's why you should read the notes I
realized one thing but it was too late
valkyries came to protect me they
protected me from blood look a few rules
gonna already be your little form so my
life isn't so easy anymore
but I just can't destroy the Machine
anymore okay why not
is this a barrel of gunpowder I think so
well let's blow it up blow it up blow it
up I'm gonna blow it up up into the sky
ah
okie dokie
it sounds like some pretty intense music
going on let me cozy star be all nice
uh-huh
okay am i good
is that all blown up now can I go back
Josh should I go back I don't even know
what this machine whoo no that's not a
good thing
all right then I guess we're done here I
can go home now right I'm free from what
the machine wasn't even bothering me in
the first place why would I be worried
about that toe behind it Oh Kim duck
oh it's getting dark okay after a long
and hard way up I went to sleep I
weren't able to find my way out tomorrow
I will escape sure you will
everything is not as you think I don't
think much at all so I wouldn't be
surprised at anything why do we why
would I still go back to sleep in the
house why wouldn't I just stay awake and
desperately try to escape like oh come
on Jon scare Omaha oh of course
[Music]
ha ha ha I saw that you can't miss me
why'd you do that whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
whoa well this isn't good there's a key
you will find out find out why the dark
truth that I'm really a monster I had
one of those dreams again there's
someone talking to me through the dreams
I don't think that was a dream bro I
think he's in trouble
Chapter three no way out
I was worried that I was getting to the
end there god there's more cuz I knew
because for one I don't know what that
machine's all about I mean it was only
introduced late in the story so I don't
even know why I needed to shut it down I
wasn't doing anything to me what right
do I have that key no I do not have a
key oh this is good
Oh grey my visions are wiggly wobbly
okay hello what is this there's nothing
there's nothing I can use here hello the
rebel villagers declared war against me
they thought that when I'll be down they
can rule this village I will torture
them when they come here there will be
my sacrifice to the gods Odin will be
proud of me
Odin be praised I need a key to this
door
there's stuff behind the paintings maybe
hello oh whoa whoa whoa what a how I
took me a second to realize what that
was
that's a person shadow thing grab the
key it's done there hey I'm gonna throw
some Maddy haba goes right through it
okay hi okay now you're gone
good haha I was freaky I really liked
some of the custom stuff they doing
these custom um complete total
conversion mods cuz they do get kind of
creative wait was it so minor nope uh-uh
lies all lies okay I got the key let's
just get out of here okay hello what's
in here some behind the paintings
ooh what the hell that's not something I
wasn't so mama
that's not what I want why is that like
that
Oh what the hell is going on here this
doesn't make any sense
okay let's see let's get the key for
this one hi owl what are you doing here
hi Alexander what are you doing here hi
moonlight what are you doing here dan
dan dan dan wait time the two I hang the
Tyler
okey-dokey god I hate that picture
there's like the most disturbing picture
of anything I've ever seen you guys
stare at it for a bit they just break on
you in a while ha ha ha
stare at it stare okay I think she's got
to assume that there's gonna be
something behind one of these paintings
it's actually useful not that I'll know
which and when it'll happen is this a
big maze seems like a maze oh good at
least I can get drunk smash
um knife knives more bottle
this guy's a drunkard is that why he's
experiencing all these weird dreams I
came from there I didn't oh did I I
don't know I thought I was still in the
dream sequence okay I'm in the real life
real bad stuff happening this really the
stench of flesh comes from fleshy
corpses corporate corporate sistas
corpses okay never mind
okay going in that room was a bad idea
because now my vision is all Wiggly
wobbly how can I have something that is
useful please and can it not be dark why
must it always be dark okay so that's a
dead end
it's a dead end over there hi I said no
darkness can I have light okay where I
haven't gotten anything that I can use
maybe I can use the crowbar on this one
huh kind of at a loss there's this weird
oh gosh darn it this is weird hand with
an apple there I don't know why it don't
make no sense
go back technically but why would I want
to Oh
[Music]
yeah it is get with the picture okay
which way do I go now let's keep moving
the way we were going hello something
down here now
alrighty then hi oh this is not good
door won't open I won't open hide behind
the couch oh not good why why I can't
fight the door change what's all that
okay you're gonna run this way and I'm
gonna go around you hot dog all right
don't kill me but oh come on ah pull
down put it down put it down boy down ah
it's a dead end
buggy off ah I got you with a box knob
Valkyrie don't lose your mind yet you
need to escape good hi this is getting
weird man this is getting weird like I
just hang in there is getting weird
okie dokie it's nice and bright in here
yup he's just hanging out to sum up here
I need why is that glowing purple well
where am I going where am I going whoa
who's that I just kind of slid off into
nothingness anyway why is there a purple
glow here I really like to know but I
don't care what's in here it's not so
dark in here I like it I like it
okay alright am I supposed to poke you
boo poked a naked dead guy haha twirl
them around like a pinata
okay alright enough playing with dead
bodies lock is broken I can't open it
what my crowbar go
you took my crowbar away from me why why
would you do that okay so obviously
obviously I need to get up into there
whoa whoa say wha okay
Oh like what random ladder in the middle
of nothingness okay so I'm now up here
can i up yep there we go okay now I'm
not drifting off into empty space yeah
there we go okay making it make oh damn
it
okay I shouldn't have gone that way go
the other way let's see if it'll
actually keep me on this thing okay
let's go this way jump around a bit
flail your arms in the air and then oh
come on
okay I'll get this later I'm already
over time so I'll get this in a bit so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done say hi to the naked dead guy
floating there and as always I will see
you in the next video
get out of here